my interest has always been in the
influence process how it is that people
can be spurred to say yes to a request
even one that they might not be
interested in in its merits the way I
got into it is actually something more
personal I've always been a sucker
always been a patsy for the pitches of
salespeople or fund raisers have come to
my door so I wound up in unwanted
possession of of tickets to the
sanitation workers ball and and and
magazine subscriptions that I didn't
really want in and I always wondered how
could that be I didn't want these things
yet I wound up purchasing them there
must be a psychology to the presentation
that's separate from the merits of the
thing so I began to study the influence
process systematically first in my role
as a behavioural scientist but then
taking a broader look I actually
infiltrated the training programs of as
many influence professions that I could
get access to I tried to learn how to
sell automobiles from a lot vacuum
cleaners door-to-door portrait
photography over the phone I was the guy
from Olin Mills I was that guy I didn't
stop there I also looked at what the
fundraisers were doing to get us to say
yes what advertising copywriters were
doing what lobbyists were doing even
recruiters arm service recruiters
corporate recruiters I even studied what
cult recruiters do to get us to say yes
and through it all I looked for those
commonalities which were the things that
were being used in common in parallel
across all of the people who were
interested in getting us to say yes to
their requests
certainly you always stand on the
shoulders of giants and for example
Stanley Milgram who did the famous
Milgram obedience research who showed
how people would respond to the
directives of an authority figure to
deliver nearly fatal levels of shock to
an innocent other person simply because
they were commanded to do it by someone
in a white coat carrying a clipboard and
professing to be a scientist professing
to be someone who was in authority in
the the lab situation where they were
working and people very many of them
indeed 65% were willing to deliver all
the available shocks that were were
there in the situation for them to use
simply because they were directed to do
so that's a very powerful psychological
phenomenon other people for example Leon
Festinger who studies something called
cognitive dissonance theory the desire
of people to be consistent with what
they've already said and done even if it
doesn't make sense in the larger sense
but in that particular situation in
order for them to be consistent with
what they've already said or done in
public they will do what seems to be
irrational things Philip Zimbardo who
did the famous Stanford Prison
Experiment
in which he showed how putting Stanford
undergraduates in the role of prisoner
or guard caused them just by virtue of
the situation to start taking on the
characteristics and the behaviors of
those problematic situations that we
find in our prisons prisoners ganging up
on one another
guards abusing the prisoners and so on
this sort of thing emerged just because
the situation was there not because of
the kind of people who were there you
can put anybody in those situations and
you get what what surfaces to be very
alarming they reenacted
can't be done with a real subjects any
longer because it was so devastating to
a lot of the people who participated
they saw themselves being pawns and
being willing to deliver nearly deadly
levels of electric shock to someone
simply because they were commanded to do
so by somebody who they didn't know that
left some of these people sufficiently
in doubt of their own self confidence
and and ethics that it can't be done
anymore the American Psychological
Association won't allow that kind of
research